tu es chaud ça se passe dans un mec qui
rentre il rentre dans une banque il
prend deux personnes en otage donc la
police le négociateur ils essaient
d'être calmez-vous monsieur sortez dit
non ma vie c'est de la merde à cause de
cette société je suis énervé votre façon
j'ai buté un otage il va il regarde la
femme sa femme elle lui dit enfin je
regarde la femme il dit écoutez je suis
obligé de buter un otage d'écouter bah
il y a pas de problème de micro vous
appelez je m'appelle Béatrice et là le
mec il commence à pleurer il pleure avec
son flingue il pleure il dit mais
pourquoi vous pleurez mais parce que mon
ex s'appelait Béatrice et la pauvre elle
nous a quitté et le mec à côté dis-moi
je m'appelle Marcel mais dans le
quartier on m'appelle Béatrice
[Applaudissements]